am belgischen nordseestrand
blankenberger kam es am wochenende zu
diesen heftigen szenen badegäste
prügelten aufeinander ein
wie jetzt bekannt wurde sollen offenbar
auch deutsche urlauber an der
massenschlägerei beteiligt gewesen sein
mit sonnenschirmen gehen sie aufeinander
los respekt vor der polizei
fehlanzeige diese videoaufnahmen aus
sozialen netzwerken zeigen deutlich
stress statt sonne am nordseestrand in
blankenberge warum die badegäste
aufeinander einprügeln laut euronews
soll zu laute musik zum streit geführt
haben eskaliert sei es damals
sicherheitskräfte die gruppe
aufgefordert haben den überfüllten
strand zu verlassen 120 beamte sind vor
ort manche von ihnen setzten sogar
pfefferspray und schlagstöcke ein um den
mob zu bändigen
mehrere prügel touris sind festgenommen
worden
das belgische planten berge reagiert auf
die ausschreitungen mit einem verbot für
tagestouristen